bald gehen die geburtenstarken jahrgänge
in die rente immer weniger junge müssen
dann das umlagesystem tragen es droht zu
wanken
ich bin mit drei abiturienten verabredet
richard julian und finn besuchten
leistungskurse in politik und wirtschaft
sie wissen dass es ihre generation bei
der rente doppelt hart treffen wird noch
bevor sie ins leben starten sind sie
verlierer des systems das treibt sie um
und dass die meisten anderen jungen
menschen die es nicht wissen
ich bin bereit ich sicher dass wenn man
das flächendeckend in schulen vermitteln
würde und erklärt wurde dass das system
und das ist und im alterspyramide in der
gesellschaft 90 oder 95 prozent der
schülerinnen und schüler sagen würden
das geht doch nicht da müssen wir was
ändern
das problem die wenigen von ihnen müssen
in zukunft immer mehr renten finanzieren
der demografische wandel trugen 2005
drei beitragszahler einen rentner
mussten letztes jahr zwei beitragszahler
dasselbe leisten
2050 werden es wohl nur noch 12 sein die
für einen rentner aufkommen
eine folge die beitragssätze müssten
steigen
der generationenvertrag könnte dann
wackeln
nicht nur müssen wir uns irgendwie um
den planet sag ich mal kümmern
nicht nur müssen wir ausbaden was sie
hier gemacht haben wir unsere fossilen
rohstoff hier verbrannt hat sondern wir
müssen uns jetzt auch noch mit einem
system was einfach nicht für eine lange
zeit geschaffen ist umschlagen julian
richard und finn werde ich später an
einem ungewöhnlichen ort wieder treffen
ich frage mich wie viel werden die
jungen zusätzlich in die rentenkasse
einzahlen müssen
in bochum an der ruhr-universität treffe
ich einen der dies ausgerechnet hat
professor martin berning gehört zu den
führenden forschern auf seinem gebiet
es ist eine erschreckende differenz also
wir haben berechnet wie viel mehr die
eigentlich zahlen bei den höheren
beitragssätzen jetzt über die nächsten
20 30 jahre und da kommen sechsstellige
beträge aus 150000 euro je nachdem
welche generation zu nehmen junge leute
sind da wirklich in einer zwickmühle sie
müssen im grunde wenn das geltende recht
gültig bleibt
für die relativ hohen renten der älteren
generation aufkommen und ergänzend
sparen problematisch zudem die politik
schuf in den letzten jahrzehnten
zusatzleistungen um altersarmut zu
dämpfen aber auch als großzügige gaben
an die heutigen rentner mütter rente
abschlagsfreie rente mit 63
erwerbsminderungsrente zuletzt die
grundrechte
eine folge das loch in der rentenkasse
muss mit steuergeldern gestopft werden
letztes jahr mit 106 milliarden euro
beinahe ein drittel des bundeshaushaltes
und es wird von jahr zu jahr mehr
also eine ständig steigende
steuerfinanzierung der rente ist kein
weg denn am ende müssen ja dieselben
stark steigende mittel aufgebracht
werden über eine steuer von etwas
anderen leuten mit etwas anderen
verteilungswirkung aber trotzdem würden
die steuern mehrwertsteuer
einkommensteuer dann so hoch dass der
druck eben dahin verlagert wird in
kassel treffe ich inzwischen ein junges
start-up der zukunftstag regelmäßig
halten sie an schulen vorträge dieses
mal digital wegen der pandemie ihr ziel
schülerinnen und schüler über rente und
altersarmut informieren etwas das
offizielle stellen
aus ihrer erfahrung nicht tun also man
man würde sich wünschen dass die politik
macht aber wir waren selber damals
schüler und haben das schulsystem erlebt
und es kam halt einfach nicht an
und darum wir sehen die probleme was die
altersarmut angeht und wir können
einfach nicht länger darauf warten weil
das system sonst weiter funktionieren
würde weil wir riesige gesellschaftliche
und soziale probleme haben und wir
wollen was dagegen tun die unsere
gesellschaft kann ich glaube ich nicht
aushalten dass die hälfte der rentner
später unter der abendspiele liegen wird
gegründet haben sie das start up vor
zwei jahren nach dem abitur
heute sprechen sie an der wilhelm
leuschner schule in niestetal
sie erklären den schülern zu hause das
rentensystem ich weiß ihr seid alle der
neunten und zehnten klasse die rente ist
ganz weit weg und das thema altersarmut
vielleicht auch wer von euch weiß denn
wie das rentensystem funktioniert
vielleicht dass wenn man arbeitet dass
ein teil davon einfach zur
rentenversicherung wir damit man später
in rente hat ja danke
lorenzo erläutert dass das eingezahlte
geld direkt an die rentner fließe
die beitragszahler würden lediglich
rentenansprüche erwerben
arme im alter sind schon jetzt zu viele
renten
es gibt 102 millionen rentner die von
armut betroffen sind das heißt es ist
ein riesiges problem und die
armutsgefährdungsschwelle die bei 917
euro das heißt man sagt ja dass man wenn
man weniger als neun holz 17 euro
verdient dass man dann als arm gilt
umso wichtiger wäre es für sie
vorzusorgen
doch in zukunft bleibt ihnen immer
weniger in deutschland sind bereits etwa
16 prozent der rentnerinnen und rentner
von armut bedroht krone hat auch ihre
not verschlimmert in der kleiderkammer
der berliner stadtmission spüren sie
dies gerhard hübsch den ich hier treffe
ist altersarmut paar monate war der 71
jährige sogar obdachlos arm am ende das
tut weh wir verabreden uns für den
nächsten tag hier im berliner süden lebt
der hat in einer übergangswohnung welche
die stadt bezahlt der betreiber möchte
nicht dass wir ihnen drehen
die hat zeigten ja fotos
es ist ja nicht schön so gestrandete
seine ist gar nicht schön für mich ist
es gar nicht wie gewohnt wird das zimmer
eines freien hilfsvereins kostet 500
euro
küche und dusche müssen sich die
bewohner teilen hat mich ein gewesen
hier die gewichtung bekommen erhalten zu
haben
gerhard rente 425 euro plus
grundsicherung also sozialleistungen vom
amt wie die miete zwar arbeitete er fest
bei der bahn aber er war auch lange
selbstständig als maler legte nicht
zurück fühlt sich das an verdeckt
beschissen einschüssen seine eigene
wohnung wurde ihm gekündigt er hat ein
schufa-eintrag findet in berlin daher
nichts geholfen hat ihm in der zeit der
obdachlosigkeit die stadtmission 0 hilft
gerhard obdachlosen verteilt
essenspakete aus dankbarkeit
ich habe gerhard von den abiturienten
erzählt und ihrer sorge um die rente und
er hat sie eingeladen will ihnen
erklären wie hart altersarmut ist mit
der bei yannic ein weiterer
ehrenamtlicher
die fünf verstehen sich yannick und
gerhard führen die drei jungen männer zu
einem illegalen kennt gerhard hat sony
gelebt aber viel fehlte nicht bis zum
endgültigen abstieg hat julian und finn
wollen wiederkommen helfen essenspakete
zu verteilen
die altersarmut wird wohl weiter steigen
so könnte 2036 jeder fünfte neue rentner
als arm gelten bei alleinstehenden
rentnerinnen wird es wohl jede dritte
sein
zurück in der kirche der stadtmission
gerhard stellt uns helga holz vor helga
hat 36 jahre gearbeitet als
zahnarzthelferin ihre rente am ende
945 euro damit liegt sie knapp über der
grenze zur altersarmut sie erhält
zusätzlich 140 euro wohngeld helga will
mir zeigen was sie tut um ihre rente
aufzubessern wegen rückenproblemen kann
sie kaum noch laufen freund oder
mercedes die 79-jährige ist
alleinstehend ihre familie kann sie
nicht unterstützen
in den fluren einiger häuser sammelt sie
zeitungen über sich um ein bisschen
tasche jetzt war immer was extra zu
können
das ist ja man im sommer ein eisbecher
oder mal essen gehen seien zu hoch ist
oder manche kuchen ja so in der richtung
landwehr so ein kilo paket zur zeit
kriegt man fünf cent fürs klima ich war
schon mal mehr
aber apropos ist ja ja ja
knapp 80 euro ganzen jahr gehabt
80 euro im jahr für den luxus eines
eisbrechers oder kuchen
aber klagen würde helga nie
die altersarmut bei frauen wird in den
nächsten jahren massiv ansteigen
doch was sind die ursachen in berlin
treffe ich manuela barisic sie ist
arbeitsvolumen und hat genau untersucht
welches armutsrisiko kinder für frauen
bedeuten
so führt im vergleich zur kinderlosen
frau ein kind bei müttern zu
durchschnittlichen einen posten in den
lebens erwerbseinkommen bis zu 40
prozent haben mütter da geht drei und
mehr kinder können diese
einkommenseinbußen bis zu 70 prozent
ausmachen je weniger ich arbeite je
weniger ich verdiene desto weniger kann
nicht in die rente einzahlen und so
verwundert es auch nicht dass diese
einkommenslücke natürlich auch ein
vorbote ist für die rentenlücke die
korona pandemie habe die lage von
müttern zudem weiter verschärft
ich will herausfinden warum frauen zu
selten an ihre rente denken und fahre
nach bayern
die meisten wollen nicht über ihre
drohende altersarmut reden in freising
habe ich mich mit einer frau verabredet
die sich nicht versteckt claudia egger
möchte andere aufrütteln
sie ist geschieden lebt mit ihren beiden
kindern allein als elena und jonas auf
die welt kommen bleibt sie zu hause
obwohl die landwirtschaft studiert hat
also ich habe immer gedacht ich bin
keine kluge so aber wenn wenn es nicht
ganz rund läuft beim kind und das war
halt damals so dass es nicht ganz rund
läuft dann wird man zur klucke so ein
bisschen später arbeitet sie in mini
jobs verdient ein wenig dazu in ihrer
rentenversicherung fließt kaum etwas
die mutter glaubt an den
familienzusammenhalt
vor fünf jahren dann die scheidung nach
der trennung erkennt claudia heger
maximal 600 euro wird ihre rente
betragen also die zahl zu sehen
das ist ein ziemliches also für mich war
es nicht gut sondern einfach nur panik
einfach wirklich so geht's nicht claudia
du musst dich bewegen mach was weil sie
jahre der familie schenkte und ihre ehe
scheiterte wäre sie im alter arm gewesen
ist das nicht auch etwas entwerten dann
fühlt man sich dann in dem moment mit
ihrem peugeot entwertet so all das was
sie geleistet haben
doch sie ist eine kämpferin
in münchen so hört sie damals soll es
eine finanzberatung speziell für frauen
geben dorthin nimmt sie mich mit helma
sie gründete die finanzberatung vor über
30 jahren rente altersarmut ein
dauerthema in all der zeit die heute
80-jährige hält immer noch vorträge
es tut mir in der seele weh wenn ich
mitbekomme dass frauen im alter arm sind
unser rentensystem ist darauf aufgebaut
dass jemand möglichst lange möglichst
viele ein zeit und wenn frauen was
tatsächlich so ist zwar zu siebte zwar
fast alle wieder arbeiten aber zu 70
prozent in teilzeit ohne sich darum zu
kümmern wie viel rente sehen kriegen es
ist auch eine tatsache dass ganz viele
frage renteninformation nicht lesen ja
sie wüssten sven sie hinschauen würden
und dann müsste ihnen angst und bange
werden
claudia heger liegt nun für die rente
zurück das was sie kann
privat fotografiert sie gerne
perspektiven wechseln sagt sie und
heraustreten aus der frauen armutsfalle
also jetzt nicht immer nur denselben weg
einschlagen sondern einmal rechts und
links gucken was kann man machen was
gibt es für möglichkeiten sich einfach
bewegen
früher sorgte ein mechanismus für eine
balance zwischen rentnern und
beitragszahlern sanken die löhne wegen
einer krise sanken auch die renten die
große koalition schaffte dies vorerst ab
was zusätzliche milliarden kosten könnte
welche durch beiträge oder steuergelder
bezahlt werden müsse
alle experten sagen dass wir zudem
länger arbeiten müssen es eine frührente
wie heute bald nicht mehr geben wird
nur wie sollen wir ihn körperlich
beschwerlichen berufen im alter arbeiten
in ulm finde ich ein unternehmen welches
zeigt wie dies gehen könnte
reinert russ ist froh hier bis zur rente
arbeiten zu können
mit 57 jahren wurde der gelernte
schlosser gekündigt seine frühere firma
war insolvent die neue stelle bekam er
wegen seiner langjährigen erfahrung ein
jüngerer kollege der war einfach zu dem
zeitpunkt familiär noch nicht in der
lage diesen diese leitung diese
teamleitung zu übernehmen und dann wurde
mir das an getragen und ich hatte da
also das war für mich eine ehre sage ich
mal ich war damals sehr stolz hoch
motiviert arbeiten die beiden jung und
alt im team zusammen ein erfahrener
mitarbeiter oder an andere mitarbeiter
hat natürlich so groß wie rabatte wie
jetzt zum beispiel einmal jährlich für
produziert baustoffe die älteren
mitarbeiter braucht das unternehmen
dringend denn bis 2030 werden millionen
fachkräfte in die rente gehen zwei
millionen facharbeiter werden dann
fehlen im unternehmen spüren sie dies
bereits
es macht uns sorgen wie wir in zukunft
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter für unser
unternehmen gewinnen können zum einen
investieren wir stark in die eigene
ausbildung und in der fort und
weiterbildung aber wir wollen natürlich
auch unsere älteren mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter ans unternehmen binden sie
befähigen dass sie auch im hohen alter
noch ihre arbeitsleistung erfüllen
können dass dort jung und alt aber auch
frauen mann für uns einsatz tätigen kann
so weit es geht digitalisieren und
erleichtern die arbeit der lastwagen
fährt selbstständig auch die produktion
mitarbeiter bekommen arbeitshilfen ein
seltenes positivbeispiel dabei wird es
für die sicherung der renten
entscheidend sein dass mitarbeiter wie
reinhard russ länger im beruf bleiben
können ohne ihre gesundheit zu schädigen
die arbeit zu erleichtern
gewichte wegzunehmen das umlagesystem
rente gerät an seine grenzen
deutschland ist für die überalterung der
gesellschaft nicht gut aufgestellt dass
für die rente zuständige
bundesministerium schickt mir
schriftliche antworten
ich hatte fragen gestellt man erklärt
dass die beiträge steigen würden und die
rentenanpassung gedämpft würde das
eintrittsalter solle nicht angehoben
werden die altersarmut werde tendenziell
steigen
zu den jungen beitragszahlern heißt es
wer heute mit 20 in das erwerbsleben
einsteigt wird in den 60er jahren
unseres jahrhunderts in rente gehen die
höhe seiner rente wird durch das
bestimmt sein was dann erwirtschaftet
werden wird
mit anderen worten das problem der
jungen wird in die unsichere zukunft
verschoben
das müsste nicht zu sein wie das
beispiel schweden zeigte baute seinen
rentensystem wegen des demografischen
wandels um schon vor 35 jahren das ziel
jüngere beitragszahler entlasten die
rente absichern
an der universität von stockholm
begleitete professor sg bundles für
diesen prozess
wir hatten eine überalterung probleme
und die leute aber sehr schön ist
griffin immer länger daher haben wir in
den späten 80er jahren das system
radikal reformiert so gibt es einen
renten teil wie bei euch aber auch einen
kapitalgedeckten teil wenn du 1 ntg ist
bekommst du nun einen teil vom
wohlfahrtsstaat und einen von deinem
angesparten abgabesystem und es läuft
sehr gut auch für die leute die nicht so
viel gearbeitet haben alle bekommen eine
art konnte wie in deutschland setzt sich
das rentensystem in schweden aus drei
säulen zusammen
die rente als umlageverfahren
betriebsrenten und private vorsorge
der entscheidende unterschied die
sogenannte prämien rente 25 prozent der
gehälter werden automatisch eingezogen
und an kapitalmärkten angelegt jeder
beitragszahler kann die anlage selbst
aussuchen schweden federte die
überalterung abbaute kapital im
rentensystem auf und entlastete so die
jüngeren
zudem arbeiten viele rentner weiter
ich besuche inga danielsen sie hat 1100
euro rente und sie managt die rezeption
eines deutschen baumarktes ein paar
stunden in der woche
weil es ihr spaß macht also ich habe
mich bei einer vermittlungsagentur für
rentner angemeldet und da hatten die
diesen job
ich hätte nicht jeden angenommen das war
aber einfach nicht hier und die kollegen
sind super ich kriege noch weiterhin
jobangebote aber hier gefällt es mir
sehr gut und ich werde bleiben solange
das zusätzliche gehalt wird nicht auf
ihre rente angerechnet wie etwa in
deutschland wo nur minijobs steuerfrei
sind für die arbeitgeber sind die
pensionäre ein gewinn
jüngere kandidaten fehlen oft und die
rentner kosten weniger steuern
mit ihrer erfahrung jetzt zum beispiel
auch die kinder sind aus dem haus
sie kann sich auch da hat man den stress
nicht mit kleinen kindern haben und die
sind natürlich auch finanziell
der arbeitgeberbeitrag ist dann auch
niedriger nicht allen rentnern in
schweden geht es blendend bei frauen und
migranten will das land noch nachsteuern
aber das rentensystem muss nicht mit
steuergeldern gestützt werden
altersarmut gibt es kaum der
demografische wandel wurde aufgefangen
reformen und einschnitten die
deutschland noch vor sich hat damit der
staat sein versorgungs versprechen
einhalten kann und wir am ende nicht arm
sind
[Musik]